it for a second as well we've got lots  of conversation threads we've got some  thai grain curry oh  you can make me lunch yeah i'm springing  it on you oh no  let's look at the thai green curry i  think it looks alright the ingredients  look good as thai eggplant in there  there's a bit of oil on the top that's  all right um but i guess we gotta try it  who made this me you no i didn't it was  may may it was my night for merchandise  yeah yeah yeah the ingredients look  correct yeah and what is this one  thai tea oh i love thai tea that's great  all right let's try this the color is  good you use enough green  green chilies you know oh i'm a fan  that's the best one i've ever had good  job man  man i'm giving that 10 out of 10. 10 out  of 10. yeah wow i'm biased  is it high praise coming from aussie man  aussie man ethan's very easy to win over